une nuit de fin mars au nord-est de la
grèce près de la frontière turque
nous longeons un fleuve qui délimite les
deux pays et les trois heures du matin
dans la lueur de nos phares des
silhouettes un homme lève les mains
il nous prend pour la police l'eau un
petit groupe tente de se réchauffer
autour d'un feu vous venez d'où de syrie
9 personnes dont un enfant de 6 ans
viennent tout juste de poser pied en
europe
vous venez de traverser le fleuve
oui en bateau et on a marché
vous voulez rester en grèce où aller en
angleterre en allemagne en france
oui en europe ils semblent perdus n'ont
personne pour les guider pas de
téléphone ils vont nous demander de leur
rendre un service
surprenant vous pouvez appeler la police
oui enfin si vous voulez vous voulez
vraiment qu'on appelle la police oui à
la demande des syriens et des bangladais
nous appelons donc le commissariat le
plus proche une camionnette se met en
route
ce fleuve qu'ils viennent de passer se
nomme evros ils courent sur près de 200
km entre la grèce et la turquie et il
est de plus en plus traversée entre 100
et 300 personnes par jour enregistrés
l'an dernier par les autorités
européennes 15% de plus qu'en 2010 ce
fleuve est il une brèche dans la
muraille de schengen est il un
suffisamment surveillé
comment l'information circule telle
entre les migrants nous avons emprunté
cette route de l'immigration clandestine
la principale de l'union européenne
[Musique]
une demi-heure après notre appel la
camionnette de la police arrive elle a
fait vite
le commissariat est à 30 km vous venez
d'où deux scieries syrie tout le monde
vient de série non je suis du bangladesh
il y en ad'autres bangladesh qui est
venu éteignez le feu s'il vous plaît on
va quand même pas mettre le feu au
village
des migrants qui appellent ou font
appeler la police
ce rituel étonnant se répète presque
toutes les nuits il se transmet de
bouche à oreille les clandestins
aurait-il à d'être pris en charge par
les autorités grecques
à vive allure la camionnette fait cap
sur le commissariat
les policiers vont prendre les
empreintes digitales de chacun des
migrants et recueillir leurs identités
des données qui seront consultables par
tous les policiers européens
si les migrants sont contrôlés dans un
autre pays de l'espace schengen
ils seront renvoyés en grèce leur
première porte d'entrée dans l'union
européenne
trois heures plus tard nous retrouvons
les syriens et les bangladais au centre
de rétention de filakio chacun efface
les traces du passage et fait sécher ses
vêtements en attendant de savoir s'il va
être expulsée ou non
l'été dernier ce centre était surpeuplé
les images avaient choqué toute l'europe
150 migrants dans à peine plus de 100 m²
[Musique]
déborder la grèce semblait incapable
d'accueillir ces migrants depuis un
centre supplémentaire a ouvert dans la
région
la jeune maman syrienne et son enfant
attendent le contrôle médical
tout le monde ya droit ses compagnons se
présentent comme des opposants au régime
de bachar al assad
le peuple veut la chute du régime en
bâche assure la partie on rentrera en
syrie vous êtes passé par la rivière oui
à la nage
vous avez eu peur hein et d'istanbul à
la grèce combien avez vous payé 500
euros 500 euros oui
sur leurs mains un agent du centre a
tracé un numéro vraisemblablement
l'ordre de passage pour la procédure
appelée le screening une étape décisive
dans cette cabine un expert et un
interprète vont tenter de déterminer si
les migrants disent la vérité sur leur
nationalité
ils ont été envoyées par frontex
l'agencé de surveillance des frontières
extérieures de l'europe
nous avons rencontré l'un de ces
screener il a appris à interroger les
migrants qui se déclarent ressortissant
d'un pays en guerre pour obtenir l'asile
les passeurs brief les migrants al
avance sur ce qu'il faut dire ou ne pas
dire pendant l'entretien du screening
par exemple quand des africains de
l'ouest ont l'intention de dire qu'ils
sont somaliens
les passeurs leur apprennent des choses
sur la somalie donc nous devons
continuellement changé nos questions nos
méthodes nous adapter
si vous demandez à un palestinien
comment il est parti de palestine
si les venues par avion et s'ils
répondent ville alors l'entretien est
finie parce que nous savons qu'il n'y a
pas d'aéroport en palestine
dans ce cas le migrant reste en
rétention le temps pour l'administration
d'en savoir plus notre groupe de syriens
et de bagdad et a le sourire après 11
heures passées au centre une signature
et ils vont être libérés
personne ne sera renvoyé de grèce cela
n'arrive pas souvent
l'an dernier moins de 2000 personnes ont
été expulsées du pays
un bus vient se poster à la sortie
pourra-t-elle le billet coûte 70 euros
les migrants ont tous en main un papier
blanc
la plupart le considère comme un permis
de séjour
un précieux sésame mais il ya méprise
ces quelques lignes rédigé en grec sont
une injonction de quitter le pays avant
un mois
vous voulez aller où je veux aller à
athènes
je veux rester là bas
j'espère trouver du travail vous avez
des amis qui vous attendent là bas
contrairement à ceux bangladais la
plupart des migrants n'ont qu'un souhait
quitter la grèce au plus vite pour
gagner un autre pays d'europe
ils ont devant eux 30 jours pour
s'organiser 30 jours de l'égalité
quel chemin ont-ils parcouru avant de
franchir la frontière gréco turque
comment ont ils organisaient leur
arrivée sur le sol européen
à seulement 2h30 de route du fleuve
evros istanbul cette métropole et le
point de passage obligé de ceux qui
rêvent d'europe venus d'asie d'afrique
ou du moyen-orient
beaucoup arrivent en toute légalité les
ressortissants des pays du maghreb n'ont
plus besoin de visa pour venir en
turquie
[Musique]
et ceux des pays africains l'obtiennent
désormais sans difficulté la turquie est
en pleine croissance
elle a besoin de main d'oeuvre
le quartier de conca fille et la petite
afrique d'istanbul c'est ici que vit
libre il a 19 ans il a quitté il ya
quelques mois la république démocratique
du congo pour sa première destination
une seule solution wavre
une dizaine d'autres pays c'est
difficile déchets chez nous là bas c'est
difficile donc pour l'apport des sorties
un peu facile sur istanbul
aujourd'hui il est décidé à partir il
également pour l'europe
je compte c'est d'avancer et pas les
mêmes en france allemagne et italie
là où c'est un pays développés quoi par
rapport à ici bonjour
bonjour libre et footballeurs ses
espoirs de faire carrière en turquie ont
vite été déçus désormais il mise sur un
grand club
pourquoi pas français marseille psg
après on verra au prévenu
va nous proposer quoi mais
l'europe avec deux amis congolais livre
à planifier son départ tito la
cinquantaine sera du voyage
c'est de kinshasa avant même d'arriver
en turquie qu'il a contacté un réseau de
passeurs
nous sommes venus parce qu'on n'avait
plus l'adresse des bruits qui chassa
depuis le pays et il ya d'autres
personnes qu'il vienne aussi après mon
téléphone et je n'ai eu une belle maison
ici vous allez laisser tranquille où il
va faire conduction ok vous passez donc
tout le monde est au coi coco lui a
demandé l'asile politique en turquie
mais la réponse tarde
il ne veut plus attendre il faut que je
parte il faut c'est mon souhait des
jauges loin dans mon bon des bandits qui
donne à la france de la possibilité qui
a tout fait mais pousse rod cpi s'est
passé pas la grèce qui nous intéresse
puisque si on va aller péter en fr pour
dix jours qu'on a fait ici un tir qui
s'est pas la peine c'est la france
belgique allemagne hollande - landrin
le voyage coûte cher il y a plusieurs
intermédiaires à payer aller jusqu'à
athènes
là il faut préparer pound et 1000 $ à
1000 $
à ce prix le passage lui a été garanti
tito est confiant on a réfléchi c'est
qu'ils sont allés sont arrivés et
pourquoi pas moi
comment fonctionnent ces réseaux les
trois amis sont en contact avec un
rabatteur congolais comme eux et c'est
tito l'ancien qui le rencontrent le
rabatteur et lui en contact avec un
convoyeur soudanais qui doit les emmener
à la frontière ou des passeurs kurde
leur feront traverser le fleuve
le groupe aux véhicules sont pas aussi
c'est à pied jusqu'au pont du larivot
toute façon c'est le grand jour
le passage est prévu dans quelques
heures derniers préparatifs
chacun emporte ce qu'il a de plus
précieux
vous savez
pour libre ces chaussures de foot
et toi comment tu te sens me concerne je
pense que ça ça
coco est le plus prévoyants des zones
jean
ultime précaution laisser ses papiers
sur place
un ami les leurs on verra plus tard voir
donc adressé faut cacher votre identité
vous avez les facettes
si coucou se fait prendre il se
déclarera somaliens tito est en train de
prier
ce chrétien c'est que rien n'est joué il
a déjà échoué deux fois mais ces gens
le rabatteur les saluts et donne les
dernières consignes
allemand rené emile badiane et péter
wight plaisir quelques heures plus tard
le voyage commence en caméra discrète
nous changerons d'appartement
va bien fermé la porte
c'est le début d'une longue nuit un
dernier coup de fil avant que les
portables ne soit coupée la situation
est confuse
les trois amis vont être séparés et tito
sera finalement écarté du voyage dans
une banlieue d'istanbul coco est libre
le footballeur ont été poussés dans un
minibus avec 40 personnes libres
semblent perdus faire
m
mais l'année
les bonnets s'arrêter
tu sais dans quelle ville on va
commun avec le méconnu
si c'est pas dans quelle ville tu vas
vanek
après deux heures de route la
camionnette dépose le groupe au milieu
de nulle part
désormais il faut marcher sans poser de
questions
[Musique]
les passeurs cure ordonne de gonfler
deux petits bateaux pneumatiques
[Applaudissements]
un premier groupe s'éloigne vers le
fleuve coco est libre le footballeur son
sommet d'attendre ils attendront jusqu'à
l'aube sept heures du matin
plus de passeurs plus de bateaux en face
la grèce
[Musique]
l'europe à portée de main
le rêve a échoué
en plein jour ils sont à la merci des
patrouilles turc
coco est en colère et la noché la route
que l'on peut faire parce qu'elle n'a
pas le choix la quitter nada speed avons
un l'argent à gaspiller l'énergie et on
est loin d'ici on est loin de la ville
ici après solution pour un thé et si la
police matra plage fait gvg faire pour
cinq jours daley concerné l'a donc hélas
ces lamelles de toujours finalement la
police turque qui surveille cette zone
militaire interdite d'accès va arrêter
le groupe
racheté la franchise journalistes locaux
libres le footballeur et tous les autres
seront conduits au centre de rétention
où ils resteront cinq jours
à istanbul nous retournons voir le
rabatteur congolais ils n'assument pas
l'échec
ils renvoient la responsabilité sur le
passeur kurdes
à l'autre bout de la chaîne comment ça
va hein on ne va pas qu'est ce que tu
peux nous dire sur ce qui s'est passé un
mois cela prouvait fabergé s'adapte
c'est la première fois pour toi voir moi
je pense que les gars à qui vous avez
pris tout vous a amené de l'autre côté
là c'est lui qui a précipité d'abord
pour prendre les gens quand on est
arrivés sur place ils avaient deux
bateaux à un bateau est passé pour vous
le débat défaite à lyon
c'est à dire une affaire tourbillon la
loi de chaque mois il ya eu deux morts
en weppes combien je sais pas ce qu'on
le laisse à quai la démo impossible pour
nous de vérifier cette information
et dis moi est ce que c'est quand même
pas la première fois que ce genre de
choses arrive où il ya des gens qui ont
payé et qui ne sont pas partis je sais
ce que ça existe
alors oui ça arrive moi qui ai donné
l'argent aujourd'hui ce type a dont tu
attrapes prévient locaux n'a pas le
temps court
d'après le rabatteur l'échec du passage
donne droit à un nouvel essai les trois
congolais devrait retenter leur chance
conclusion les autorités turques ne
laisse pas passer tous les migrants
comme le montrent ces autres images mais
font-elles le maximum l'union européenne
en doute les interpellations côté turc
semble avoir lieu principalement deux
jours il y en aurait très peu la nuit
ce qui est sûr c'est que le fleuve evros
est plus difficile à franchir qu'il n'y
paraît en hiver et au printemps son
débit augmente les chavirage de bateaux
de fortune sont alors très fréquent l'an
dernier 48 personnes ont été retrouvées
noyées quand les habitants signalent des
cadavres au milieu des branchages
les policiers grecs l'hérault pêche
la plupart de ces corps ne seront jamais
identifiés ils sont déposés à la morgue
d'alexandroupolis la plus grande ville
de la région
le docteur pavlidis a vu passer tous les
cadavres repêchés dans l'evros il en a
quatre en ce moment dans ses chambres
froides les hommes circoncis
son présumé musulmans et enveloppé dans
un linceul blanc
selon la tradition de l'islam
il porte souvent beaucoup de vêtements
les uns sur les autres
parce que les passeurs ne leur permet
pas d'en porter leurs effets personnels
c'est bien qu'ils enfilent leurs
vêtements de rechange sûr on a déjà
trouvé des corps habillés de trois
pantalons de 4 chemise de deux veste
quand les passagers chavire dans leur
bateau gonflable surchargé au milieu de
la nuit
le revêtement gorgée d'eau les fans
couler comme des poids les corps sont
enterrés dans ce cimetière sans pierres
tombales le cimetière des migrants
vingt ont été portés en terre depuis le
début de 2012
plus de 300 ces dix dernières années
à l'aller
c'est un chef religieux musulman un move
ti qui veillent sur leur peau de sésame
sans nom dans cette région de grèce vit
une importante communauté musulmane
je souhaite que ce flux de migrants
s'arrêtent chaque fois que j'en en
terrain je dis mon dieu faites que ce
soit le dernier
mais le flux des migrants n'est pas prêt
de se tarir
les experts s'attendent même à le voir
augmenter avec les beaux jours
l'été dernier quand le niveau du fleuve
était au plus bas
trois cents personnes franchissent et
chaque nuit la frontière question est
elle suffisamment surveillé par les
grecs pour des raisons historiques liées
au conflit avec les turcs
la frontière est une zone militaire
truffé de miradors il y a des mines
antichars mais malgré cette apparente
étanchéité les grecs n'ont pas les
moyens de filtrer à eux seuls les
migrants les autorités ont donc demandé
l'aide de frontex l'agencé de
surveillance des frontières extérieures
de l'europe
leurs caméras thermiques distingue des
silhouettes dans l'obscurité
celle des migrants qui traversent le
fleuve
des images également prises
d'hélicoptère sur l'eau en gris clair on
distingue un bateau
l'an dernier d'après frontex 140 passeur
aurait été interpellé en partie grâce à
cette technologie
les policiers grecs aussi installe des
caméras
ici une vingtaine d'écrans permettent de
surveiller un tronçon très particulier
la frontière terrestre 12 petits km où
le fleuve fait une boucle et où il
suffit de marcher à travers champs pour
passer d'un pays à l'autre
à gauche la turquie à droite la grèce et
pour la frontière terrestre l'état grec
est un projet qui fait couler beaucoup
d'encre une clôture de 12 km les travaux
de terrassement ont commencé
pour l'heure la police est fier de nous
montrer ce petit prototype la barrière
sera construite sur ce modèle mais plus
renforcés et plus riches afin
d'interdire totalement l'accès aux
migrants venant de la turquie sur le sol
tchèque
ça sera dissuasif
la construction de la clôture nous
permettra de mieux nous organiser le
personnel qui surveille la frontière
terrestre pourra être réparti sur des
endroits plus difficile à contrôler
[Musique]
problème l'union européenne jugent ce
projet de clôture inutile tout comme
certains habitants de la région
dans la petite ville de souffler nous
avons rendez vous avec un maire très en
colère il craint que cette clôture ne
rabat encore plus des migrants vers le
fleuve
toute cette vague d'immigration va être
déplacée sur la partie sud de l'evros
c'est tout ce que la clôture va nous
apporter en échange de cela ça va nous
coûter 5 millions d'euros qui ne sont
pas pris en charge par l'union
européenne mais qui va lui falloir
trouver dans une grèce appauvri sans que
cela ne résolvent aucun problème j'en
suis persuadé et le maire ne peste pas
seulement contre cette barrière
toutes les solutions mises en oeuvre
jusqu'à présent pour lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine lui semble
dérisoire avec lui les experts européens
de frontex en prennent aussi pour leur
grade
prenez cette histoire d'hélicoptères il
passe la nuit c'est de l'argent jeté par
les fenêtres pour nous dire par où
passent les migrants mais mon petit
bonhomme qu'est ce que tu veux que ça me
fasse
on sait très bien où ils sont on les
voit arriver ici même sur la chaussée
pas la peine de nous dire qu'ils sont en
train de traverser
et ces clandestins que le maire voit
passer chaque jour ne reste pas dans la
région la ville de reste yada et l'un de
leurs points de départ pour athènes dans
les rues de nombreux migrants en
provenance de turquie
c'est là que nous rencontrons nadia elle
se dit irakienne nous ne serons pas
grand chose de son passé si ce n'est
qu'elle est veuve en turquie le passeur
lui avait vendu un aller simple en
voiture direct pour athènes il ne m'a
jamais dit qu'on devrait traverser une
rivière
c'est seulement en route qu'il nous a
dit qu'on devait traverser il était trop
tard pour moi pour faire demi tour et
j'ai compris que la rivière était très
dangereuse que des gens étaient morts
dans cette rivière là maintenant
j'attends bus avec les autres on va à
athènes
et vous savez où vous irez ce que vous
allez faire
non je sais pas du tout le bus l'attend
athènes est à 900 km
deux jours plus tard dans la capitale
grecque
nous retrouvons nadia elle cherche un
moyen de sortir de graisse pour
rejoindre l'allemagne
il lui faut un passeport
un trafiquant l'a approché pour lui
proposer une drôle de combines le boulot
de ce type c'est de convoyer lui même
des gens jusqu'en allemagne avec des
vrais passeports
nous serons quatre il va m'emmener chez
les coiffeurs me maquiller choisir mes
vêtements pour que je ressemble à la
photo du vrai passeport qui leur a pour
moi mais nadia n'a pas assez d'argent
pour payer le prix demandé
il veut 4000 euros je vais lui proposer
trois mille je n'ai pas d'autre solution
je ne veux pas rester là si nadia est
pressé de partir c'est parce que dans un
mois elle sera illégal en grèce le
fameux papier blanc aura expiré
aujourd'hui on est le 30 mars une
semaine s'est déjà écoulée et la police
ne m'a donné que 30 jours de l'égalité
justement son intermédiaire l'appelle
pour lui fixer rendez vous il a peut
être trouvé le passeport avec la bonne
photo
elle a du mal à faire confiance en cet
homme
mais at elle vraiment le choix nous la
quittons sur cet instant d'incertitude
[Musique]
selon les estimations du gouvernement
grec à moins de 130 mille migrants
seraient entrés illégalement en grèce en
combien d'entre eux ont réussi à gagner
des pays européens moins touchés par la
crise impossible de savoir une chose est
sûre il est plus compliqué de sortir de
graisse que d'y entrer pas évident par
exemple de se faufiler dans l'un de ces
ferries pour l'italie pour faire cap
vers l'ouest
les frontières sont autrement plus
difficile a forcé
[Musique]